that's what I need bro you are [ __ ]
[Music]
I'm Jade Arena I'm here to answer the
internet would you rather have a good
hand job from your grandmother or a bad
hand job from your grandmother
[Laughter]
I'm a typo
both my grandmothers are dead you want
it to be good but that's weird because
then your grandma made you come
that's what's going to happen your
grandma's going to get you off you're
going to get a full jizz off of your
grandma have like that memory of like
remember that time grandma was just like
two-hand double pepper cracker yeah
really jerking me off like is she doing
the thing where she's kind of like got
her arm around me she's like Whispering
my ear and she's got like her leg up on
me or something she's really [ __ ]
jerking me like that yeah or though but
you think about the bad one where it's
like Grandma's just ripping me to shreds
down yeah the good One's Gonna Take time
yeah
long One's Gonna Hurt You know a balance
can be long and hurt but you're not
gonna be like
the word I just think the worst thing
that can happen though is the next time
you go to jerk off you're like I wish
Grandma was here I think you
do brain to go there I think I would
rather it be good because I wouldn't
want to have to lie to my Grandma that
her [ __ ] was good because if your
grandma gave you a bad hand job you're
gonna be like oh no Grandma was great it
was great it was a great [ __ ] I loved
it I loved it and I'd rather her just
[ __ ] go on her last year as being
like I still got it I can still [ __ ]
jerk it right out of a dude's dick if
you saw that one of your friends
accidentally posted a dick pic on
Snapchat would you tell him or let or
leave it up I would for sure tell him
I'd be like absolutely I tell them but I
might like screenshot it or something
I'd be like Yo dude your dick's up like
because if my dick was up or one of my
buddies would tell me that my dick
sucked but at the same time
it depends on how nice the dick pic is
like if he put if he got a shitty dick
pic posted I would feel bad but if he
had like a rocket of a dick pic posted
I'd probably tell him but be like hey
man let this one ride let's see how many
likes this gets like another half hour
put it on Reddit
we can move this would you rather have a
girl who talked a lot during sex or a
girl who was completely silent during
Tech sex I'm a [ __ ] huge talker I
want words I want all sorts of stuff I
want you saying [ __ ] up dirty [ __ ] in
my ear like your deep dark [ __ ] up
things if you're silent I can't do [ __ ]
all with that I need like a uh like
specifics [ __ ] me this way I'm a piece
of trash whatever the [ __ ] you're gonna
hit me with like I a big thing for me is
whoever I'm hooking up with we talked
about this on the Pod I need you I don't
give a [ __ ] what you look like I just
want you to be a [ __ ] and I can tell the
difference I can tell the difference
between someone who internally in their
soul is a [ __ ] and someone who's faking
it and when it's which is better oh it's
better when it's the real thing I don't
want it to feel like you're doing this
for me I wanted to feel like you can't
not do it like if you don't do it you'll
feel shitty and you'll like go murder
someone or something that's what I need
brother you are [ __ ]
pull the internet would you rather be
filthy rich in the 1900s or poor now I
think filthy rich in the 1900s because
I'm not white so like my my dad's black
my mom's white and so back then I'm
super black I'm super in New York I'm
half black half white but if I go to
like white Canada I'm full black that's
how that works but yeah so then I could
just be like a rich ass black dude
stunting on white people being like yo
look all the [ __ ] I got that you don't
look at you poor ass whites and [ __ ]
become like a legend I'll be your
[ __ ] the sixth [ __ ] out there
I for sure would get like an HBO series
now about this Rich ass badass dude who
[ __ ] with white people back in the day
holy [ __ ] that would be sick would you
watch a sex tape of your number one
celebrity banging your arch enemy
I don't think ah you don't want to see
them win I can see your face I can see
your face right now like and to have
them banging I really I really don't
want that to happen I don't want them to
get like anything good happening to them
ever personally no I don't know who
would say yes to this it says [ __ ] 63
abortional readers said yes oh because
you get to see them get [ __ ] you know
what I think is the good part about it
is I can see my arch enemy in my head
and I know they're kind of like a
doughboy they're [ __ ] a soft pudgy
person
yeah no no no no I'm keeping this one in
the [ __ ] chamber I'm not losing this
watching them [ __ ] is probably going to
be embarrassing for them because that
sex tape is going to go viral and then
all the comments are gonna be like who's
this fat [ __ ] who's sweating and can't
[ __ ] like that's gonna be all the [ __ ]
so maybe yeah I do go yes on that if you
could only watch one actor's movie for
the rest of your life who would it be I
think [ __ ] Samuel Jackson Marvel
movies you get a bunch of like comedies
and [ __ ] you get Pulp Fiction you get
[ __ ] Black Snake Moan you've never
seen plastic
one year me and my buddy we were
streaming we did a Christmas special
where we watched Black Snake Moan and we
soda streamed eggnog we like Carnage
that's like a challenge and watch black
snake mode if you could wipe one group
off the Earth who would it be cyclist
done done we're done with cyclists
there's a difference between someone who
rides a bike and a cyclist you ride a
bike you go from A to B I hate these
[ __ ] you see that got like the
[ __ ] the tights and the shirt and
there's like a logo on it I'm like well
you got sponsors are you doing the Tour
de France no you're [ __ ] 40 and you
have no personality and you live in the
suburbs and you got [ __ ] all else to do
so you spend a bunch of money on this
[ __ ] and now you're like oh it's a
[ __ ] it's like the embodiment of
shitty Suburban consumerism slapped on a
person and then they inconvenience you
as you're driving it's all so many
things I hate on top of itself would you
rather [ __ ] a chick who's banged a
thousand dudes or chick who's banged one
out this isn't even how are these the
same
weird [ __ ] yeah of course okay it's a
73 a percent of Barstool readers chose a
of course who are the [ __ ] other what
is that 23 she really wanted to cut you
and hurt you she'd be like you couldn't
even [ __ ] as good as that dog and then
you're like oh would you rather have 50
Grand straight to your bank account or
half a million in pennies and you can't
convert it oh Jesus Christ you can't
convert it in any way you can't even
like melt it down and like turn it into
something else can I put it in the bank
though no I know me and I know who I am
and I know if I had all these pennies
what's ended up happening is I'm just
gonna like throw them out or some [ __ ]
I'm like literally it's gonna become
trash they're gonna be everywhere it's
gonna be a burden on my life having all
these [ __ ] pennies I'm not gonna like
oh roll them and spend them and be like
Oh I'm being responsible no it's gonna
be like [ __ ] sand in my house or some
[ __ ] I got a beach in my house now yeah
50 grand for sure 100 would you rather
live for the rest of your life with the
sensation right before you sneeze [ __ ]
or come hmm I think I choose come
because I would know it's not gonna
happen like right before you come I
think it's like there's a sense of
pleasure to that too it's like a
Euphoria you're excited for it when I'm
about to [ __ ] I'm not excited to [ __ ]
and then I would never know when I'm
actually going to [ __ ] that would be a
problem yeah because you're like just a
fake thing exactly and the sneeze too
the sneeze can get really uncomfortable
come for sure because when you're about
to come you're like [ __ ] sick that
might even be a motivator maybe I get
more [ __ ] done because I'm like chasing
this [ __ ] feeling all the time yeah I'm
like yeah I'm about to come I'm feeling
the best I'm I've ever felt which
fictional character would you love to
beat the [ __ ] out of oh this is a good
one I think beating the [ __ ] out of
Superman would be great because if you
beat the [ __ ] out for one he's like oh
boy scouty and like oh I'm such a nice
dude and it's like [ __ ] you dude but you
beat the [ __ ] out of Superman you're
really [ __ ] pull you that's like
that's forever in my Tinder bio like I'm
[ __ ] I kick Superman's ass like
that's huge I'll get a [ __ ] like shoe
deal off of that like that's a big
[ __ ] ticket item beating the [ __ ] out
of Superman you'll get invited to like
the Legion of villains or whatever like
Lex Luthor's gonna buy you a [ __ ]
Mercedes-Benz like I'm getting a lot of
[ __ ] leeway out of this maybe you
[ __ ] I don't know I could get a movie
deal or something I'd kicked the [ __ ]
out of Sprint forever a tough cut would
you stop masturbating if every girl you
jerked off to knew you were doing it
no
that might even be a great opener yeah
and also say you like flirt with a girl
at the bar something happens to you like
I [ __ ] didn't get her number you
[ __ ] jerk off to her she gets a
[ __ ] pig she's like hey that's like
hey never [ __ ] come near me again I'm
putting you on a list maybe I think
people like to get jerked off too I do
is jerking off to webcam girls cheating
absolutely not absolutely not I didn't
know there's no there's no chance like I
think if you're only jerking off to them
not cheating that's [ __ ] fine if as
soon as you start typing on the keyboard
you're cheating okay as soon as there's
[ __ ] communication it's a good line
it's before that it's porn before that
it's porn if it's live porn whatever
it's like live edited pre-recorded it's
all porn because in the end that's the
same porn it's like it's just you're
viewing something that stimulates you
that's making you jizz that's not
cheating once you bring yourself into
the situation and you're dictating
what's going on then you're [ __ ]
that's cheating would you rather live
your life as is or be a billionaire but
you have to blow a dude every day who am
I blowing that's an important part let's
let's just like the most average dude
most average dude
like he lives in the suburbs he's an
average guy he's like 41. yeah drives
like a Honda Odyssey for the kids he's
like not in good shape not in bad shape
and is it the same guy
every day the same guy he shows up and I
blow him you're like hi hey Jeff Jeff
how long does it take him to come uh it
depends on how big you are sucking dick
oh yeah I guess it would get better over
time and like learn his Kinks and stuff
by the end of it you're like popping
fingers oh yeah and I'm making him come
like crazy I think I I take the
billionaire I suck a dick every day
because one I don't have to worry about
anything but the worst thing in my life
is sucking dick but also I'm probably
getting like a really good friend out of
this
like this guy's gonna be my friend for
like ever like we're gonna have cities
yeah we're like yo let's get this done
yeah and he [ __ ] comes and I suck his
dick and then it'll like we hang up we
talk a little bit I'm like hey dude good
to see you good to see you the only
shitty thing would be is like if I
wanted because you're a billionaire
you're gonna travel and do [ __ ] I gotta
take him with me I got to be better be
friends oh yeah yeah we're gonna have to
hang out a lot
thank you for watching answer the
internet please subscribe to the channel
comment below on other celebrities you'd
like to see and make sure you hit the
Bell to get notifications when new
episodes come out